Part of preparing for a job interview...
...is to make sure you look like you would be a good addition to your prospective company.
Monster is here to help with the ultimate guide on what to wear to a job interview.
Think about the company and the industry you're hoping to work in.
Is it a casual or a more formal environment?
There's no shame in phoning up the HR department to ask about dress code.
It's a good idea to dress as if you're already part of the team.
Dressing the part alone won't get you the job regardless of how clean your shirt or shiny your shoes.
However, it could put the employer off if you fail to follow some basic rules.
Most importantly, don't dress too casually.
Stay away from tracksuits, trainers and t-shirts.
A smart pair of trousers and a shirt are the absolute minimum expected of you.
Women should be wary of showing too much flesh.
Your cleavage and midriff have no place in the interview room.
You should be relying on your other assets to get you the job.
Careful when it comes to headgear.
Hats can make you look like you have something to hide.
And be wary of too many accessories as these can be a distraction.